hi happy whatever today is I thought I
would vlog today since I haven't blogged
in a little while I'm back in Los
Angeles and Poppy's here hi honey we're
out of focus we're out of focus say
hello to everybody we're about to go for
a walk and then puppy is going to go to
the groomers I think I've been telling
you guys previously and some of my
tweets in my videos the little Maddy has
some sort of allergy we think it's a
food allergy we're not really sure I've
taken into so many different vets and I
don't know what's wrong with him
it's okay look I like look he just looks
like eating himself alive it's it is the
most heartbreaking thing that I've ever
had to experience it's just like
watching him be just miserable and I'll
just go grab him grab him in a little
blanket and say oh it was my skin day
everything's gonna be okay bud maddie is
currently five-and-a-half pounds if you
guys remember when I first got this
little boy he was only one pound a whole
pound could she was eating eating your
body you flush you're eating your flesh
so after the groomers right now I also
wanted to tell you guys to go check out
the quest video that I did I actually
was beyond in shy knew I was coming to
quest to do a shoot to do a cooking show
they didn't tell me anything they said
you might want to bring a change of
clothes just in case so I was like all
right well cooking shows I might get a
little messy did I get messy it took me
like an hour to get all this stuff off
of me if you'll watch in the video I
took the pie filling which I liked the
protein powder and everything else in it
and put it on my head but check out the
video it's a requests new pumpkin pie
quest bar and there's a bunch of other
youtubers and it to your show maybe
you're a meaty little man are you ready
to go to the groomers just okay we're
gonna push you down now there you go
look at that who's there is that you oh
do you want to go for a walk are you
tired
do you wanna treat sit good boy
oh you did a good job are you just are
you showing off with a camera because
usually you run away like
oh boy we gotta go let's roll I can't do
it you're playing dumb I know how you
are you're smart let's go come on you
can do it you're gonna go down the step
no leave it
nope nope nope nope successful poo come
on goodness let's go the struggle is
real this is a great run we've got going
on here huh yeah yeah he's working up
great things are going well
mine mine you ready to go get your hair
cut somebody looks super cute but still
bitin himself
oh my little man I was like be careful
he's my baby
hmm I had them cut you so short he looks
oh my goodness you're so damn Maddy come
here come here show us show us your body
show us your little body oh you're so at
you honey
Hey look here Maddy come here Maddy sit
Maddy down he said try not to get him
cut for a while sighs like just cut him
short so we don't have to worry about it
for a long time
but boy are you a sweet little soul Oh
give me news kisses your nose kisses are
so sweet those cases are so sweet I
thought I didn't want to teach him
kisses but Bri taught him kisses my
prince and his camel anxiety sweater
armor no itches baby no eat cheese do
you get anxiety when you see the camera
is that what's happening we gonna play
let's play
well how much fun we're having okay yeah
are we gonna go to yoga today I've like
not prepared to leave him alone for too
long so I'm not gonna go so I was like
well maybe I can just see so we'll do
that if you don't do that maybe I'll
just do some at-home yoke we do our
downward dog and he did not want to have
anything to do with it just keep
fighting myself I didn't get a
dermatologist appointment yet because I
wanted to wait to see bath the groomers
helped so we'll take you some time this
week II know this is bad he doesn't even
know leave it so I made a few Mario
maker levels I'm probably gonna post so
this my gaming channel it's been so hard
to just manage having a puppy who
doesn't feel well and make youtube
videos Plus gaming videos I stopped it
not to make gaming videos like I thought
that big of a deal which is why I
actually like not having a schedule I
know I should and are you guys may like
to have consistent content but like
who's in there who's in there
is that Maddie bear is that Pinkie Pie
are you what time is it I don't want to
say the H word if it's not time for each
word you stop it are you hungry Maddie
are you hungry are you hungry I think
somebody's hungry look at my hungry
little puppy like I swear I feed him I
feed him a lot he just is always hungry
little hoglet do you know that's on your
head do you even know that's on your
head
Maddie oh my god it's just heartbreaking
you don't even know what's on your head
alright well thank you guys for watching
today's vlog I will keep you updated on
the pace up I'll keep you updated on the
Maddie adventures and also my iPhone
adventures it's been working perfectly
fine since the burn gate as everyone has
been calling it so I'll see you guys
later and go check out my gaming channel
for the Mario maker levels and I think
that's all I have to say today it is
yeah bye hey I'm gonna I'm gonna boil
your
your finger I can try to use such ID or
turn your phone on it won't turn on